Hi, there, I'm Seth Juarez,
and I'm here for the Microsoft
Research Faculty Summit
2017 where the theme
is the Edge of AI
and I have a couple of guests.
So, tell us who you are and what you do,
my friends, we'll start with you.
- My name is Manish Malik,
I'm an applied scientist at Relevance
in the AI team of Bing.
- Fantastic, and you, sir?
- And I'm Nilesh Bhide, Program Manager
on the Relevance AI team.
- Fantastic.
So, what do you do in general?
How do you help us find things better?
Why don't we start with you, buddy.
- Well, that's what we're going to talk about today,
working on a project called, "Infobots."
- Okay.
- Which is a conversational
Q&A system which really tries
to understand the conversation
and tries to answer the questions
for the info seeking questions
that users are asking.
- I see, and why is that such a huge challenge?
I'm trying to understand, because I can go onto Bing
and type some crazy query and then,
I get a thousand things and then I can search through
and I can get the answer.
How are you making this better?
- So, you know, traditional search indexes the web,
and you try to rank all the documents up there,
and then, you try to find the best
10 documents to answer your question.
- Okay.
- And then, you have to basically go
into each one of them
and try to find the information.
Which is a pretty arduous task.
- Sure.
- This pattern actually breaks down on mobile
because you have a tiny screen.
You know?
Try looking at this long document
and trying to find this information.
The smart speakers, they don't even have any screens,
so how do you when get to those full links
to get the answers that you need.
That's where this paradigm
becomes very important.
- So, what?
You keep talking about
this new paradigm.
Why don't you describe that paradigm for people
who are watching so we can get a sense
for what are we actually doing.
- Yeah.
So, what we're noticing, Seth,
is in this revolution of AI,
and in this time,
people want to be able
to talk to machines
and people expect machines
to be able to understand
the conversation,
understand the context
behind the questions.
And get the answers directly
without having to read a lot of documents
that the traditional
search engines provided.
Malesh talked about the speakers.
You know?
There's a lot of devices that are coming to the market
where there are no screens.
And therefore, we have no other option
but to answer the questions directly.
Think about a user that wants
to travel to Singapore
and if they say, you know, "Singapore history."
And you know,
in the current system today,
they'll have to read documents
to understand the history
and if they have more questions
like what is the religion,
what is the ethnicity,
what is the area and population?
In the traditional search engines,
they'll have to repeat Singapore all the time.
Repeat the context of
Singapore all the time.
And we are trying to solve
that problem here,
and we are trying basically
to answer the questions directly.
We feel that if we can save users time,
this will not just make search truly useful,
it will also make the AI
revolution stronger
and make, you know,
search a lot more intelligent.
- I see.
So, Malesh, what does this
actually look like in practice?
If I'm a user that's using this new
paradigm what would that look like?
Do you have something to show us?
- Yes, perfect.
Actually, I'll show you a quick demo
of the Bing Infobot.
- Okay.
- Which is the AI-powered bot that we have.
So, today, if you go to Bing search engine,
you type in Singapore history,
as Manish mentioned,
you get a tiny piece of snippet there
talking about the history.
But you have an option
to actually chat with the Bing
Infobot to find more information.
- I see.
So, this is literally you are talking to the computer
and asking it questions directly?
- Yes.
- Because I was a little confused.
I was like, usually we type something in
and then we get an answer,
and I was thinking there was more
of a refined way of searching,
but you're saying, talk to the thing directly.
- Yes.
- Okay.
Let's look at that.
- In this case, you're going to message
the thing directly because it's a chatbot.
- I see.
- And so, in this case,
you know, since the bot already knows my context,
I don't have to keep typing the long queries here.
I can just say, "Hey, what about ethnicity.
And, you know, actually,
Bing is actually
going to Wikipedia,
billions of documents trying to find
the right information for you.
And you have this information
snippet right there.
- Oh, I see.
So, what you're saying then is that,
when I'm searching for something,
instead of typing Singapore,
and then, typing Singapore ethnicity,
Singapore history,
Singapore population,
the bot already understands
a lot of the context
that we're in
and is able to answer
those further queries.
- Not only that.
- Okay.
- It understands the context,
but it goes one step further.
You can do natural
language-based queries.
Because, suppose I do it's religions.
Now, that I know about Singapore ethnicity,
I really want to see which religions are practiced.
So, let me show you a couple
of demo queries here.
We are actually finding the information
and giving information
that Singapore has actually 10 religions
that they practice over there.
- Oh, I see.
- And if I say is, "English spoken there?"
Because I want to know
before I visit that country
whether I need to learn some new language
or I can converse in English.
I can get this information, the bot understands
natural language
semantics of this and you
get a perfect answer.
Singapore English is English
spoken in Singapore.
- So, this is, I mean, this feels natural
and the demo is so unsurprising
because it feels like
you're talking to a human.
But in the back end, there's
a fair amount of AI that's happening.
- Yes.
- Because I studied some NLP
and question-answer systems
are very difficult to do properly.
Can you tell us a little bit
about the AI that was involved.
Why don't you tell us
what happened, Manish.
What is some of the AI that was involved?
- Yeah, so let me show you the next set of demo
and I'll highlight what we are building in that.
- Okay.
So, if you go up there, Malesh, to the questions.
- Yeah.
- This is good.
- So, the question
is a rattle snake venomous?
And, you know, of course, we are able
to extract the answers, but look at the highlighting.
So, what we are doing is
really reading comprehension.
We are first, extracting the passages
or pieces of information
from the documents
that contain the answer.
But that's just
the first step.
The second step of reading comprehension
is we are then extracting the specific answer
from that passage
and highlighting it right here
so we can say the answer
to the question
is rattle snake venomous?
We are highlighting the specific answer.
If you go down, you'll see the next question
being, "Is King Cobra venomous?"
And here, we are actually
building an inference model.
Which is not just extracting the answer,
but really able to infer the answer,
and again, going back to the point
of saving users time.
So, here, you'll see yes at the top,
and that's coming from our inference model,
and we are now saying, that yes,
based off of the information
we found in the document,
the model is able
to really infer that knowledge
and answer the question
directly right there.
- Which is more next level, because it's,
I mean, it's pretty good feat
to be able to look across the documents
that are accessible to Bing
to answer a question,
and, then, highlight where the answer is.
But then, to go further and say, yeah,
and here's our evidence
is pretty amazing.
- Yeah.
And going back to that point,
because it's a hard problem.
Look at the third example,
"Is garter snake venomous?"
And in this example, you know,
although, we have the answer,
the answer is not very straight forward.
It's not a yes-no-type of answer
because the passage is saying
that although common garter snakes
are not considered venomous,
they have a gland
which produces some venom, right?
- So, it's not very obvious.
And our model can now really understand
where, you know,
how they infer knowledge
from the pieces of text
for a query to answer the question
when to answer the question
directly or show the passage,
and you know, there are
several parts of AI
that has gone into building our system.
If you think about conversational
Q&A, there are four big pieces.
One, how do you understand
the conversation, right?
Which is the case of Singapore
history and ethnicity.
We need to determine whether
that this question requires context
from previous questions or not.
And the second is, if it does,
how do you take the context
and understand the question, right?
- So, what does that look like, for example,
if I'm going to ask a random question
into the bot, you know,
"Who invented the printing press?"
"How old was he when he died?"
- Yeah.
- Is there some kind of stack
that's being generated in order
to remember
who the "he" is, right?
- Yeah.
- How do you do that?
- That's a great question.
So, there are three parts of that system.
- Okay.
- The first part is we store context.
Which is, we call context as previous questions
and answers that we gave the user.
So, the questions that users asked and the answers
we provided in that session, so, that's our first part.
Second part is our lead
model which is an R&N,
it can take the context
and the current question
and reformulate the current question
to make it fully independent.
And the third part is
once you have re-formulated into,
you know, multiple
possible options,
you know, replacing he with,
let's say the person,
exactly, the person
that's being talked about.
How do you know that you
re-formulated correctly
because there could be
several different options, right?
So, that's our third part,
that's sort of meat and potatoes
for what we do in Relevance.
And we are now, we look at
the post-web signals to really figure out
how do you pick the re-formulation
that makes the most sense.
- So, it looks like the three-step process
is number one, you need to get the question out.
Then, first you need to know
what the question is, then,
if there's any indirect
object pronouns,
for example, you need to replace them.
You need to replace them
in an intelligent way.
I'm assuming you'll have multiple candidates.
- Exactly.
- That happens, and then,
once you use your inference
engine to find out,
then you go and answer
the question like you did.
- Right.
I mean the first step there,
you have to extract
the entities and concepts.
- Sure.
- From the questions, right?
And so, that's also where a lot of work
that has gone into the Bing stack.
- Yeah.
- So, what does that look like?
First of all, Bing has got to be
this tremendous area of information
where you can get all this data out of,
but you have also the riches of data
that you have to search through,
but it's unclear to me
like how you're using Bing
to answer the questions
and then what are you doing
with the questions themselves,
because you have to, there's a lot of
understanding the questions, right?
Why don't you tell us about that.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
So, there are several parts of this system
where we are truly leveraging Bing.
But we're also building some really amazing piece
of AI technology to solve the problems.
So, let me explain.
The first piece is
the conversational understanding.
Given a context, how do you
understand the question?
As simple as that.
It sounds pretty simple but there are
a lot of models that are being used
and we use Bing Stack
to the fullest in this area.
For example, if the question,
if the question you said,
"Who acted in Star Wars
Episode Five?"
And the next question is,
"Who directed it?"
Or, "When was he born?" Right?
So, there are a lot of pronouns
in these second questions
and these are very easier, easy cases
because when there is pronoun,
you can make the argument
that pronoun needs to be
resolved through the context
that was there earlier.
So, we have, you know,
code reference resolution models, we have deep models,
trained using a lot training data
that can take the context
from previous questions
and resolve the current question
to understand the question better.
But that's just
the first part.
You know, once you understand
the question better,
the next big part is how do you
retrieve the answer?
- Right.
- So, for that,
as well, we fully leverage Bing.
So, we get the results, Bing today
is already very good
at saying what documents are good
documents for a question, right?
But, what we do on top of it,
is we break down the document barriers,
we break it down
into pieces of information
that those documents contain,
and then, rank those
pieces of information.
Let's make it simple, call it a passage,
so a document can have different passages.
We rank the passages,
we pick the best passage.
So, that's where we use Bing a lot.
But then, the very next step
is once you have the passage,
how do you extract
the specific answer.
And that's really reading comprehension
and we've built retention models that can,
you know, train on a lot,
a lot of training data
to given a question
and a passage,
extract the appropriate answer.
And the last step, which is also very important
is once you have extracted the answer for a question,
how do you machine writing?
How do you say it in a
very natural language way
so that the users can trust the answer
that you've provided.
For example, if the question is, "What is the net
worth of Bill Gates."
And if a machine
just blurts out an answer
which is $300 billion.
You know, you might be
wondering was that really...
- Was that really Bill Gates,
or was that the other question?
- Exactly.
And then, what we are doing, is we're building
a model that can machine write
which can take the question
and the answer
and can convert it
into a very natural
language response.
It can say something like, "According to this website,
I found that Bill Gates net worth is $320 billion."
And that is a much natural response
that users can understand,
they know the source of where
the information came from,
and they know that they know
something that they can trust.
- And that's, I mean,
that's pretty amazing right?
Because, once you've done essentially,
you've taken what Bing's really good
at returning documents,
you've actually narrowed it down
to Bing returning Passages
and then they're using
your machine learning models
to infer the proper answer
with the correct context.
Is that about the sum of it?
- Yes.
And you do this at a web scale, right?
That is where the Bing's strength in dealing
with the entire Internet comes into play.
And this is a very general
technology that we are building.
So, you know, it's really not specific
to only one type of document.
It's a general models that we are building
that can be leveraged across the Internet.
- So, is this something that's available now.
For example, let's just say I want to open
a home improvement store,
and I want my bot
to be able to answer stuff
based upon stuff on my own website.
Is that something that can be done?
- It could be absolutely done.
It's just that we have to enable it for that website.
- Sure.
- We have the information about that website
if it is a public domain website,
we have that information.
It could be very easily turned on
from our site to answer this question
based on that website.
So, that's the beauty of it.
We can modify the entire web without it,
the web-masters having to do anything.
That information is already there,
we can do machine reading comprehension and machine
writing on top of it
and give you the answers
that you need.
So at any time, I can have any one
chat up my website, it'd be like,
"Hey, so tell me about
your terms of service,
how long do I have to block?"
Then, from this particular
type of technology,
the bot will be able answer
succinctly and give you the passage as well.
- That's correct.
- That's pretty amazing.
So, when will this type of stuff be available?
- So, we are heavily experimenting right now.
- Okay.
- You know, in some sense,
we're really truly creating a new category of product,
a new direction of where
we want the search to go.
We want search to become
truly intelligent, truly useful.
We want to save users time
and that takes a lot of iterations.
We are, as I said, experimenting a lot,
tweaking the experience,
understanding how users are reacting,
and what's working
and what's not.
But, and, you know, as soon as we get to a point
where we feel pretty good about how users are behaving,
and what information
we are providing,
and whether they are liking it
or not, we'll release it.
It might be sooner than you think.
- That's amazing.
I'm excited for one day I'm going to have my own shop
and I'm just going to ask my computer,
"Tell me, how do I make my own robot?"
And then, your robot is going to tell me
how to make a robot
and we will have robot inception.
[Laughter] Thanks so much,
Manish and Nilesh for spending
some time with us on,
"How to make search more intuitive."
It's been awesome, thanks for watching,
and we'll see you next time.
- Thank you.
- Thanks.